shut up  [Music]  does he have any houses or he just by  himself  [Applause]  [Music]  foreign  90 seconds  I'll be nice  okay okay  let's go  is everyone off is everyone has everyone  be quiet  um  if it's the same guy  24.  95  not even okay  [Music]  [Music]  all right  bust his ass  thank you  thank you  okay  let me try to talk again yeah  oh my God  30 minutes  all right  guys  don't cooperate you're gonna be taser  all right I need you to stand up for me  okay  stand up come on stand up walk right  here you're gonna be tasers  look that way  listen relax  just relax  [Music]  go on well stop man relax you relax and  put the handcuffs on right man  come on man hey man  what's wrong with you man  my phone right here